we begin here demanding answers all the
way to capitol hill now
why was a powerful teachers union
seemingly allowed to dictate
cdc apollo cdc policy on when america's
schools could reopen
i'm harris faulkner you are in the
faulkner focus 20 house republicans
are led by house minority whip steve
scalise
and they say they're launching an
investigation into alleged improper
outside influence on the cdc by the
american federation of teachers
right now about one-third of students
across the country are still
not back in their classrooms full-time
the lawmakers are asking cdc chief
rachelle wielinski
to hand over those communications with
the aft
that's a major democratic donor some
republican senators yesterday questioned
dr wilinski over a report which shows
the agency used feedback
from that teachers union word for word
in some parts of cdc guidance
why is having offline secret
negotiations with one stakeholder
as a matter of practice the cdc engages
with stakeholders
with consumers who take our guidance it
suggests that aft leadership
they certainly changed the language
of the guidance it was the cdc
scientists
that provided the guidance that provided
the science around what we should do
steve scalise house minority whip and
ranking republican on the house
coronavirus subcommittee is here with me
now
congressman it's great to see you today
my first question is
is the cdc in trouble
harris i think the cdc is in trouble
because they're being asked very serious
questions
and you go back to the campaign
president biden said he was going to
follow the science
and then here you had science saying
most schools could reopen in fact the
scientists were saying
all schools should be opened and they
were getting ready to come out with that
and all of a sudden the teachers union
said well we'll wait we don't
want to have to go back into the
classroom and let students back in
and so you saw them change it they
changed some of the basic metrics
of science that were going to be used so
that then instead of
having most kids back in the classroom
very few kids
about ninety percent of schools stayed
closed because of that change in metrics
undermining the science
and that was done by the bond
administration they've yet to answer for
it we're trying to get those
communications
because this is hurting kids it's
hurting millions of kids across america
who may never make up this difference of
not being
in the classroom when they should be and
the science says they need to be
real quickly and i want to move on to a
more big picture question
but how important or critical is it to
know
that the aft was a huge donor
uh democratic donor oh it's it's very
important and again it's something that
should be on the table for discussion
when you heard president biden saying he
was going to follow the science
and all of a sudden he throws the
science out the window because
a special interest donor the teachers
union
says that they don't want kids to be
back in the classroom learning and we've
seen this in so many states where
parents are just rising up even in
berkeley when the teachers union head
is telling all the teachers you know
don't go to class you can't be in the
classroom
and then they see him taking his kids to
private school in the classroom
that double standard is just people are
going livid they're infuriated
because they know it's hurting their
kids and they're watching these union
heads
take steps that go against the kids san
francisco just to get a money grab is
going to go in the classroom for one day
so it shows you they can be in the
classroom if it's about grabbing a bunch
of money but if it's about helping your
kids
they're not in the classroom uh this is
a dangerous place to see
what they're doing long-term damage for
our kids
what you're talking about is out in san
francisco they're going to open up all
the schools so that they can qualify for
that cash and then go right back to
where they were again
tons of questions about that i want to
go though a gestalt view 37 000 feet the
big picture
there seems to be some heat building
here you've got all of this
over the covid19 school closures and the
overall handing really of the handling
of the pandemic by this current
administration
trouble getting americans back to work
representative scalise
a massive crisis on our southern border
violence exploding in the middle east
the pipeline hack that's causing panic
buying of gasoline
i mean the list actually is a little bit
longer than that and the big picture
leadership from the white house where is
it
are americans hearing enough from
president biden
president biden's leadership is
non-existent and you just mentioned
a number of crises that we're seeing the
crisis at the border has become very
evident
uh the president still won't acknowledge
and go down to the border
a gas gas prices are through the roof
and people are now waiting in line
there was a major hack by russia likely
president biden doesn't want to confront
that
you're looking at home prices right now
because of lumber prices
going through the roof an average home
is over 36 thousand dollars more
than it was a year ago look at what's
happening right now with unemployment
eight
million jobs are unfilled right now and
president biden
just ushered through a very partisan
bill to pay people
billions of dollars not to work when
eight million jobs are unfilled
right now we're paying people not to
work and they're borrowing money from
our kids and our grandkids to do it
we've seen this on every front uh and
the economy is really in a
delicate spot we're seeing inflation
starting to go through the roof
our country is less secure look at
what's happening around the world the
middle east iran
who the president wants to let back into
an agreement to get a nuclear weapon
there they're
helping uh funnel these bombs that are
being uh
being shot into israel i mean where's
the president's leadership on any of
these crises
well and where is he to answer the
questions on all of this i mean
specifically with iran and what's going
on between the palestinians and israel
right now
what's breaking off really into a very
volatile situation this week alone
we can't have access through our press
corps to the president of the united
states to ask about how that iranian
agreement or negotiation
affects or infects what's going on with
policy that we would have toward what's
happening with israel i mean we can't
get there
uh we've got jinsaki but that's not
president biden so we think i wonder
and she's trying to encourage him not to
answer questions
well and that's what we're hearing if if
there's something different than show us
a house hearing underway right now the
topic
on violent extremism and the response on
the january 6th
capitol riot congressman is this unfolds
you're now asking the fbi to reopen the
investigation
into the 2017 shooting at that virginia
baseball field that left you
gravely injured god bless you you have
recovered
but life-changing your injuries and
along with several others who were hurt
why the push for this now
you know my colleague brad wenstrup who
he's a congressman but a medical doctor
who saved me
on that ball field he started asking the
new fbi
director ray uh why the fbi classified
this as suicide by cop
everybody who knows this this what
happened on the ball field knows it
wasn't suicide by cop he went there
to kill every republican on the ball
field he had a list of names
of other republicans he wanted to kill
and thank god for the heroism
of capitol police who by the way were in
plain clothes they were not
dressed out as officers that they they
were plain closed
uh so he didn't know that they were cops
and they get into a shootout he was
trying to kill them they both got shot
david and crystal in the shootout that's
not suicide by copping yet that's how
it's classified by the fbi
other agencies have called it domestic
terrorism which is more what it is we've
asked
the fbi to go back and and just update
the record to reflect this properly
but also to let us know why it was
classified that way in the first place
when everybody else
who's given it a classification called
it domestic terrorism
yeah i mean if you can talk about what's
going on in one place we can certainly
learn
uh our lawmakers and police officers
under attack and another
to get to the answers congressman
scalise great to have you on the program
thank you very much
great being with you harris thanks